Take a look at the back of any iPhone and
you'll see a familiar phrase that's been printed
on almost one billion units of the iconic
product.
Designed by Apple in California.
Assembled in China
Like everything at Apple, that wording is
deliberate.
Apple designs the exterior, writes the software,
researches new technologies and develops its
own chips in California, which allows it to
to sell devices for 65 percent more than their cost
But iPhones are assembled in China for a reason.
It's easy to assume that reason is cheaper
labor.
While wages are lower, this doesn't tell the
whole story.
In fact, assembly is only 2% of an iPhones
hardware cost.
Today, most iPhones are made in two chinese
cities: Shenzhen and Zhengzhou.
Favorable government policies helped Shenzhen
become the electronics factory to the world
… with Taiwanese company Foxconn its biggest
employer.
As a result, thousands of companies and millions
of workers have moved to the southern Chinese
city to be close to the action.
During peak iPhone season, Foxconn hires almost
a million people, cutting its workforce to
a few hundred thousand during low season.
Such a cluster effect in Shenzhen means that
most of the components needed to make a phone,
a laptop, or a drone are within a fifty mile
radius.
Attempts to recreate this cluster have so
far failed.
Brazil is the perfect example…
Apple was facing high import tariffs in Brazil
and urged Foxconn to make iPhones there.
After securing local incentives, Foxconn built
a factory.
But very little changed.
Rather than doing lots of high-level manufacturing
in Brazil, Foxconn continued to do most of
the work back in China where the supply chain was nearby and parts could be preassembled.
This meant that most of an iPhone was made
in China and merely shipped to Brazil for
local workers to slot together like lego.
In the end, the Brazil project failed on two
levels - it hired a fraction of the workers
the government had expected and it didn’t
attract any of Apple’s hundreds of suppliers.
If an iPhone is to be made in the U.S., it’s
more likely to follow the Brazil model, not
the Shenzhen model, which means far few jobs
and for those workers, making for Apple would
be as seasonal as picking apples.
So while the U.S. could one day boast an iPhone
"Assembled in America."
the question is, does it really want to?